the issue of deregulation and the issue
particularly of corporate tax is that
something where you know is there a from
America's point-of-view first not just
some G's but from america's point of
view is there something you particularly
want him to do in that in that field
well let me start with Texas first so
you basically have an economy that is in
and what I would call an investment
recession
you know the consumers spending
companies aren't reinvesting back in
capital expenditures and things like
that in the United States that's been
going on for a long time
tax reform is one way to encourage that
to encourage that right behavior so I
think in in so far as our tax policy is
30 or 40 years old if we could get some
improvement that's going to help GE but
it's going to help everybody broadly
it's a symbiotic is it just purely
simplification or is there sort of
radical rethink to do it look I mean I
think people follow what the tax code
says right one part of it is just
simplification the ability to repatriate
capital around the world just be just be
like Germany or the UK or Japan that
would be great that'd be amazing and
then if you want to help exporters or
manufacturers or or try to change the
balance there's ways to do that right up
speaker Ryan has a plan the president's
talked about things some of those would
be helpful in doing there's a
possibility that this is an area where
business can have us at a benign effect
on the administration look I think it's
a place where you're gonna have
different camps and business who have
different you know I I respect Walmart
but we're gonna have a different
perspective on tax reform to this
Walmart doesn't mean they're a bad
company or G's good or vice versa we're
gonna have a different starting point as
it maintains that so I think all of our
voices need to be heard but if the
president can't act on tax reform with
Republican Congress and Republican
presidency that is a big miss for where
we are right now and then I think on
regulations but the fact is regulations
have exploded now we need regulations
but they should be massively simplified
and and and I think the president's
right to instincts for that is the way
some people look at this thing that
actually regulations and these sort of
complications actually help
companies like GE because you have you
have the ability at least this idea
within HR you know again I here's what I
would say regulations differentially
punish small businesses much more than
big companies because we can hire as
many lawyers as we need to write it's
hard for a small company I would make
another point that the more complicated
we make globalization it's not gonna
stop me from globalizing because we can
we can have a local team in every
country around the world if we have to
but it takes every small company that
ever wanted to globalize they're now off
the grid they they're gonna have no
chance to globalize in that in that
world so it might play back to the big
multinational we go back to the world I
suppose before the current global area
when companies like GE had separate sub
subsidiaries all the way around the
world and they they functioned in
different one again I I read your old
publication economists had a had a story
saying big multinationals are really
going to struggle in this new world
I think it's precisely wrong it's there
precisely wrong we're the only people
that can navigate in this world you know
really we're in a hundred eighty five
countries when I go see the president
Nigeria I bring in a room full of
Nigerians you know III can get business
down an end goal I can finance business
and Angola when their own Treasury I can
trust if you were a small company in
Boston trying to export to Nigeria
without free trade it's no child a
chance yes not one chance so again if we
want to create jobs in the United States
we need some relationships around the
world that's that's where that's where
business people can communicate with the
president to say let's have more friends
there's one last thing on that tax
reform I think you alluded to this basic
idea of solving the the corporate tax
headache of companies like yours having
all these there's money or show that you
would like do you think there's a deal
to be done that I really do I think
there's there's always been a deal to be
done I think you know the question is
what's the what's the tax rate coming
back in where where the cap will be used
we're quite open discussion and it's the
basic deal one where the corporate tax
rate goes down but all the deductions go
exactly exactly and and you know for us
when we have cash flow receipts us
because we do business overseas you know
that's that's what we sell things in
Europe and
in other places so it's it's not a
nefarious you know got three guys in a
building in Luxembourg or something like
that it's because we're selling gas
turbines or jet engines or things like
that